MARC COHEN: We're going to spend
some time talking this
afternoon about building robust
systems on top of
Google Compute Engine.
My name is Mark Cohen.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer at Google, and I'm
joined by--
JOE BEDA: I'm Joe Beda.
I'm the lead engineer
for Compute Engine.
MARC COHEN: So we'll hope to
give you some good ideas,
things to think about,
techniques and approaches to
building reliable systems.
This is a quick overview of
what we're going to talk
about, just a quick review
of background.
I'm assuming most of you have
probably heard about Google
Compute Engine and know about
it, so we'll just give a real
quick overview.
We'll talk a little bit about
why you should care about this
subject, what sorts of bad
things can happen when you
build these large,
complex systems.
We'll review a bunch
of power tools.
These are unique capabilities
and techniques that we believe
really bring some value to the
table when you're building
these sorts of distributed
systems.
And then we'll review a
prototypes application.
So a little bit of background.
So this is a photograph of
Google's Council Bluffs, Iowa
data center.
This comes from a very
informative website,
google.com/datacenters.
So it's a great resource if
you're interested in learning
more about the data centers.
But the quote here is from an
article Steven Levy wrote for
"Wired" magazine last year, and
it speaks to the enormous
scale and just the incredible
magnitude
of these data centers.
And I like this as a way of
thinking about Google Compute
Engine because at its core, what
Google Compute Engine is
about is getting you into that
room, giving you access to
some of the world's most
advanced computing resources.
So a quick run-through of
a description of what
Compute Engine is.
Before I launch into this, how
many people have already heard
about Compute Engine and
know what it is?
OK, cool.
And how many people
have actually used
Google Compute Engine?
OK, that's awesome.
It's an Infrastructure as a
Service product, and for most
people, that immediately
connotes virtual machines,
Linux boxes, things like that.
And that's certainly the heart
of the offer, but we like to
think of it as a very
comprehensive package of
capabilities.
So in addition to the virtual
machines, you get some very
advanced networking
capabilities.
You get a private network with
a built-in DNS server, a lot
of built-in security
capabilities like
automatically encrypted hard
drive and things of that
nature, and an array of pretty
advanced storage capabilities,
which we're going to
review shortly.
But at a broader level, it's
all built with Google's
fingerprint.
So all of the experience,
knowledge, engineering insight
and operational management type
know-how how that's gone
into building out all of the
services that Google provides
serving billions of queries a
day all around the world--
all of that's gone into Google
Compute Engine, both in terms
of technology at the design
level and also the technology
that we're building on top of.
So we're really taking advantage
of a lot of the
history here.
As well, it's part of a
broader platform of
capabilities we call Google
Compute Engine.
So as you'll see, it enables
you to work really well and
easily with other aspects
of the platform.
So I have been given talks about
Google Compute Engine
for a while, and at the end of
the talk, I often see this
expression.
And frankly, it's been
frustrating because my answer
is always very measured
and complex.
And I'm really, really happy--
I may be one of the happiest
people here--
to be able to answer this
question more simply than I
ever have before.
So the answer is yes,
if you would like to
try this, it's available.
We announced Wednesday it's
available for anyone who would
like to sign up and try
it, and I'd strongly
encourage you to do.
So it's really important to
switch gears a little bit to
building complex systems and
what sorts of problems we
might have and what sort
of things can go wrong.
Anything can go wrong, and
everything can go wrong.
And I think it's really
important to realize that your
hardware is never going to be
perfect, your software is
never going to be perfect, and
your processes are never going
to be perfect.
So there's a mindset shift that
I think is a little bit
subtle but really important,
which is instead of focusing
on building perfect things and
writing perfect code, it's
also really important to build
and design systems that
tolerate and deal well with
failures because they're
certainly going to happen.
And that's a big part of
Google's legacy, the whole
concept of MapReduce and these
huge data centers that I've
been talking about.
The core principle there is
deploying huge numbers of
inexpensive computing devices
and dealing gracefully with
the fact that in that sort of
volume, bad things are going
to happen and are in fact
happening all the time.
So to be a little bit
more specific--
whoops, didn't mean
to reveal that.
I think you guys
already saw it.
I was going to ask the audience
if you had any idea
what the single most
common factor is
in outages and failures.
You guys already saw
it I think, right?
So it's the human error.
It's making mistakes with
configuration, procedures, or
just accidental operation
snafu.
And so that's one big factor,
one big type of failure that
you'll encounter.
Then of course there are
software errors like resource
exhaustion, logic bugs.
Bad recovery code is a fairly
interesting scenario because
it's the situation where
you've written code
specifically to deal
with problems.
By its very nature, that sort of
code doesn't typically get
exercised very often and often
is not tested thoroughly.
And so what you can have there
is a situation where the code
that's dealing with a problem
makes the problem even worse
if it's not behaving properly.
Of course, we have scheduled
maintenance events and
unexpected, unplanned
maintenance outages-- or not
maintenance outages but
simple outages.
And then there's a wide
range of security
failures that we can have.
So there's a lot of things
that can go wrong.
And there's really three
dimensions to this problem of
dealing with these
sort of outages.
There's the infrastructure
layer, there's the application
layer, which you guys are
responsible for, and then
there's the process layer
or the people layer.
And we're going to focus today
on the infrastructure and the
application.
We're going to talk about the
infrastructure that we provide
and share some tips about how
you can take advantage of
those capabilities.
But I do want to spend a few
minutes on the human and the
process element, because
I think that's a really
important aspect
of it as well.
This quote captures a lot of
what I've been thinking about
in this space.
If you get a chance to check out
this article, "How Complex
Systems Fail," I highly
recommend it.
It's by Richard Cook.
It's about a four-page
article.
It's hot-linked off of these
slides, which I'll release
after the talk.
But anyway, it's a very nice
taxonomy of how complex
systems fail.
And one of the points in this
document is, "Recognizing
hazard and successfully
operating inside tolerable
performance boundaries requires
intimate contact with
failure." So what he's really
talking about is, practice
makes perfect.
It's really important to have
people who are well trained in
this area and have good
monitoring tools and are
following processes that are
going to help you navigate
that fine balance between--
it's not a binary, everything's
working,
everything's not working, but
you're trying to make sure
that small failures that are
happening all the time are
well contained.
So here are a few process
guidelines that we've learned
at Google have been very helpful
for us with managing
our systems effectively.
Set reliability goals
and track metrics.
So make sure to delineate what
it is you want to accomplish
in the space of your reliable
systems and then have good
measurements.
If you just state a bunch of
goals, and then you don't
measure it and track how you're
doing, then it's not
really buying you
all that much.
Document everything.
So any problems you're having
or issues you're overcoming,
it's really important to capture
those with postmortems
and to make sure you're
documenting all of the
learnings that you're having,
sharing it with
your team and so on.
Otherwise, you're going to
repeat those problems.
Automating everything
is really important.
Any time you have a manual
procedure in your operations
processes--
so somebody has to go click a
button or write a script or
run a script--
that's an error waiting
to happen.
So this is an ideal.
It's very hard to do this
perfectly, but this should be
the goal that we're
all striving for.
Preparing for maintenance
events and
outages is really important.
At Google, we have regular
events where we simulate
outages and actually break
things fairly intrusively.
And it's a great way to not only
prepare for but also to
test outages and events.
And build a really strong
capacity planning model and
allocation of your resources and
zones so that you have the
ability to move things around
as and when you need and to
adapt to outages on the fly.
So that's by way
of background.
I'm going to turn it over to Joe
now to talk about some of
the power tools.
JOE BEDA: Thanks, Marc.
So I'm going to cover a little
bit of the unique capabilities
of Compute Engine and how you
can use those to solve some
problems in this space, but also
some things that exist
outside of Compute Engine proper
and how you can go
ahead and use those.
To start with, you have
to know your storage.
So much of reliability comes
down to making sure that your
data is there.
It's frequently the bottleneck
that you're going to hit.
And so I want to review some
of the storage options with
Compute Engine and with
the Cloud platform.
So to start with, starting at
the least reliable level, we
have Scratch Disk.
This is a block device attached
to a virtual machine.
It lives and dies with
that virtual machine.
It's cheap and cheerful, but
it's also not very durable.
And one of the things that you
should be aware of is that
it's also prone to correlated
failures.
So you don't know that you won't
see a lot of Scratch
Disks dying at the same time.
So something to keep
in mind as you're
building your processes.
So things like good backups,
even if you're using
replication, is a good idea.
Next is our Persistent
Disk offering.
This is replicated off of the
local machine over the
network, and it's
very flexible.
And we've built it for fast,
consistent performance.
I'm going to go into a little
bit more detail in the next
slide here.
So the next is Cloud Storage.
This is the first thing that
actually goes outside of the
zone that the virtual machines
are running in.
And this is a blob storage, and
it's really a Swiss Army
knife when building
your application.
It's great for getting
information in
and out of the cloud.
It's great for storing
things for backups.
It's great also for serving.
So it really can play all those
different roles, and
it's really a great tool
in the tool box.
Next are hosted databases.
And so with Google, we have
Google Cloud SQL, and we have
the newly announced Cloud
Datastore, which is the App
Engine Datastore built on top of
BigTable exposed as an API
to anybody who wants
to use it.
And we use lead the Data Store
and the technology underlying
the Datastore all over the
place inside of Google.
And so the best thing to do is
let it be somebody else's
problem to worry about
reliability
and to hold the pager.
And so finally, you can bring
your own Datastore.
I mean building on top of
these tools, you can run
something like Cassandra.
You can run Mongo.
You can run whatever you're
comfortable with and whatever
solution actually
fits your needs.
Obviously, it's going to be a
little bit more complicated
the deeper you get, but
your freedom's there.
So just focusing in a little
bit on Persistent Disk.
It's really a sweet spot
in terms of durability,
flexibility and consistency.
That's what we really
built it for.
One of the interesting
capabilities here is the
ability to take snapshots.
This is great for backups.
There was a talk earlier at
I/O-- and you can watch the
video-- that goes deep into this
system and some of the
best practices on
how to use it.
I encourage you to take
a look at that.
And it's also a very useful
thing to move data between
different zones and
different regions.
So if you take a snapshot in
Compute Engine of a Persistent
Disk, that snapshot is
available globally.
And so it really starts to
approach a disaster recovery,
or at least a piece of a
disaster recovery plan.
And so you can use this for
anything that you would use a
disk for, database storage, fast
boot, static data that
you want to share widely, and
for being able to move data
between different zones
and different regions.
So, "Tooling should be used
automate every step." So
Adrian's actually here
in the audience.
He's see the Cloud Architect
for Netflix.
Is that your right title?
Yeah, OK.
And I was talking to him last
night, and he said, "automate
all the everythings," which
is pretty much what
it comes down to.
So here are some building blocks
that we can use to
automate your deployments
in Compute Engine.
So the first thing
I want to talk
about is Instance Metadata.
There are other clouds out there
that provide a way to
provide a passive blob into
your virtual machine.
We've taken it to the next
step and added a few more
features there.
And it's really a pretty simple
feature, but it's very
powerful also.
The idea is that from the API,
you can specify some simple
key/value pairs, and those
key/value pairs are then made
available inside the
VM at a very early
stage of the boot cycle.
And so you can then use this
to pass in all sorts of
information that can configure
your system and make your
systems be more reactive.
And you can set it both on an
instance by instance basis, or
you can set it across
your entire project.
And so this is what we use to
distribute, say SSH keys into
the virtual machine.
And so we give you some
quick examples here.
So this is using the gcutil
command line tool.
Obviously, you can do all of
this stuff with the API also.
But here I'm passing in
two metadata values.
One of them is a role with the
value of master, and then the
other one is a configuration
file coming from a text file.
And then once I boot up my
virtual machine with that
information, I can
SSH into it.
And then with a simple curl
command to a local metadata
server that's available only to
that virtual machine-- so
it's a private metadata server
for that virtual machine--
I can then go ahead
and retrieve
these key/value pairs.
So this is a really critical
building block for building
automated, self-configuring
systems.
So building on top of that, we
have simple Start Up Scripts.
So this is the next
level here.
And so this is like rc.local
if you're familiar with
traditional Unix
init processes.
And you can use this to install
packages, download
things from Google Storage
using our service account
feature to do so securely,
or bootstrap
other management systems.
So if you're using something
like Puppet or Chef, this can
be a great way to get those
things installed and working.
So here's a quick example
of what this is.
On a CentOS machine, it
will install node.
And so the first four lines
there are providing access to
an extended repository,
installing node.
And then the next three lines
are getting the specific role
that this thing should be
running, downloading the Start
Up Script or the program from
cloud storage, and then
running that.
And so with a few lines of code,
you can turn something
from being something that you
have to SSH into and push
configuration for to something
that can actually draw and
automatically run what
it needs to run.
And you can see how you can just
simply pass this in as a
metadata value for Start Up
Script, and our stock images
know how to check for that
metadata value and start
running the script
for you at boot.
And then the log gets written
to var/log/Google so you can
debug it when things go wrong.
And then on top of that, how
do you manage images?
Images can be a real problem.
And so this is a quick pattern
I'd like to show you of
creating a script that can be
used both for customizing a
system at runtime, initializing
something for
creating an image, or
initializing a Persistent Disk
that you're booting off of.
So it's an easy way to mark--
this was left over from my
fractal demo that I gave on a
previous talk--
it's an easy way to mark whether
you've done a set of
steps so far.
And if you have, skip that--
those are generally the time
consuming, one-time set up
type of things--
and then actually run
the program that
you're looking to run.
And so finally, you can do a lot
with these set of tools,
but it'll only take
you so far.
And so the next step is this
broad category of systems that
I've been calling
orchestration.
You can start with something
simple like doing a bunch of
what I've provided here through
App Engine, which is a
good way to have a system in the
sky managing it for you.
But if you want to move past
that, there are a whole bunch
of systems like Chef and Puppet,
or commercial partners
like RightScale and Scalr that
can really help you take this
to the next level.
And they all offer a different
set of features, but here's a
good smattering of the types of
things that you can expect
once you start taking advantage
of higher-level
systems like that.
Now, the next thing is that
scaling and stability really
go hand in hand.
If you're building for scale,
a lot of times you're also
building for stability.
And all the problems that only
happen once in a while all of
a sudden start happening
all the time.
And so these things really
do go hand in hand.
And so one of the key things
here is use Load Balancers.
I mean it seems obvious.
Load Balancers give you scale.
But Load Balancers also give
you the ability to route
around failures, and so they're
really going to be a
key part of any architecture
that's going to
be built for stability.
And then finally, plan to
actually distribute yourself
both across zones and
across regions.
That's both insuring against a
meteor hitting or software or
hardware failures.
And if you do it right, and if
you build an advanced enough
architecture, you can actually
provide lower latencies to the
people where they are.
And then the last feature I
want to talk about is our
startup times, our Fast Startup
Times at Google.
This lets you build more dynamic
applications that can
start and stop instances.
And if you get into the mode
of thinking about these
instances as being ephemeral
workers, as stateless as
possible, something that you
can manage and that can
self-configure, then you're
well on your way towards
building a much more
reliable system.
And being able to spin things
up and down and build that
into the fabric of the
application that you're
building really encourages
you to do the right
things along the way.
So with that, I want to turn it
back over to Marc to give a
demo that he's been
working on.
MARC COHEN: Thanks, Joe.
So I'd like to review a very
simple app that I've written
to try to illustrate some of
the concepts we've been
talking about today.
I call it Ping Me!
And the idea behind this app is
that we're going to serve a
web service from a
cluster of VMs.
We will deploy it on a very
simple stack, very
lightweight, Node.js, the
Express web framework, and
WebSockets to have some fun
with interactivity.
What will happen is the server
that you reach will be
selected by our Load Balancing
capability with built-in
health checking.
So to be clear, I'm previewing
something that we're in
testing mode with right now.
So it's not an openly available
feature of the
product, but it's something
that we're
actively working on.
And I'll give you some
information at the end of the
talk about how you can find out
more about that feature.
So the way it'll work is you'll
connect to the Load
Balancer-- or we'll connect
to the Load Balancer.
A random server will
be selected among
the available resources.
And once you have the page
drawn, we'll click a button to
ping the entire concept.
And the idea is that
your pings are not
really TCP/IP pings.
They're not ICMP layer pings.
They're application
layer pings.
We're just sending a little
short text message to the
selected server via WebSockets,
and that server is
going to turn around and
distribute those pings to all
of the client web apps connected
to the same server.
As well, it's going to
distribute those messages to
all of the connected servers.
So basically, your messages will
get shared throughout the
entire cluster.
And it's going to be built on a
very simple self-configuring
dynamic, shared-nothing
cluster.
And the other interesting thing
about it, it's only 200
lines of code.
So this is a trivial app in
many ways, but I think it
illustrates how much you can do
with Google Compute Engine.
I think the reason it's so
small is a lot of the
capabilities you might have to
build yourself are built right
into the fabric of
the product.
This is what it looks
like in action.
And we'll actually run it live
in a few minutes, but I want
to first take a few minutes
to show you some code.
So it's built on two files,
app.js, a typical node server
app, and index.html, the file
that it's serving up when you
connect to this app.
So we listen on port 80, and we
use the Express framework
to wrap a few type
of get requests.
The first one is just
a simple route path.
Get request will return
index.html.
And this health path, it gives
us the ability to respond to a
health check from the
Load Balancer.
This is nice because we can
define the semantics of what
it means to be healthy at
the application layer.
So we can just have that
blindly return OK--
200 OK, I'm happy.
Or we can build any sort of
application logic we want to,
to fine-tune what it means to be
healthy and thereby affect
whether we get requests
routed to us or not.
We're going to listen for two
types of events on the
connected sockets.
So after we've served up the
index.html, the client's going
to make a WebSockets call
back to the server.
And we're also going
to get incoming
connections from our peers.
So the first type of event
is a browser ping.
That's when someone
presses the button
to send us a message.
And what we're going to do
there is turn around and
forward that to all
the connected
browsers and all the peers.
And so right away, that raises
the specter of things
traveling around through loops
in a directed graph, and we
don't want that.
So you'll notice that the
forwarded ping event handler,
ie, incoming pings that come
from peers in the cluster,
will only be distributed
to the browsers, not
to any other peers.
So that's how we avoid loops.
And of course, that implies that
all of the clusters are
strongly connected
and in a mesh.
And we've got a bit of logic
here to make sure that that
happens, and it happens
automatically and dynamically.
And here's the index.html
that gets served up.
So here's the ping button, the
all important ping button And
we have two divs to hold the
display of the servers and the
incoming pings, and that's going
to be a real-time stream
of the pings.
The connect function is defined
here and called at the
bottom, and that is going to do
the WebSockets connection.
So I'm using the Socket.IO
library.
And here are two event
handlers for on.ping.
That's where a message comes in
to us from the server we're
connected to.
And all we want to do
is prepend that
to the ping's div.
And that way, we'll put it
at the top of the list.
And so everything is going to
stream upward, I guess.
It's like a stack essentially.
The newest stuff
will be on top.
And this is the action
to do when you
click the ping button.
Yeah, I think I messed up the
name there, but that's
basically just sending
a ping to the server.
OK, this is just a
system diagram.
The user fetches the index.html
going through the
Load Balancer.
It gets assigned a web server,
and then it can ping and have
the pings distributed locally.
And then we'll show also a
multi-server capability where
we fetch the page, we do the
ping, we get the local update,
and then it also gets forwarded
to the peer, and we
have remote updates happening.
So let's take a look
at that now.
So this is actually going to
fail because I don't have any
VMs created.
I'm going to start by
creating some VMs.
So I have a little script
here called Add,
which looks like this.
And the gc.util command that you
see here is doing all the
heavy lifting here.
I'm just looping over
the input arguments.
I'm going to put 0 and 1 in the
US Central 1A zone, 2 and
3 in the Central 1B zone.
And I'll just create
0, 1 and 2 for now,
and we'll add 3 later.
JOE BEDA: One thing to note
here is that command line
looks pretty complex,
but that was
generated using our console.
So when you actually go to
launch a VM from the console,
you can go ahead and do it
right there or actually
capture a command that you
can go ahead and script.
MARC COHEN: Right, thanks.
And I wasn't quick enough to
show you, but those things
that are spinning weren't
there a second ago.
They immediately came into view,
and they started up.
And you see they're all green.
They've actually come up.
That's how fast we start VMs.
And as Joe said, there are some
really nice capabilities
built right into--
this is our new Cloud Console,
and it's a very nice, updated
web user interface
for administering
things across the cloud.
So you can use this for lots
of the Cloud product, but
we're going to focus
specifically on Compute Engine
here today.
So we now have Servers 0, 1 and
2, and we have this model,
which is the genesis
of those servers.
I'll try to talk about that a
little bit, but I've done a
trick similar to what Joe showed
you where I have a
model server.
I customize it, add packages, do
everything I want to get it
ready, and then I take
a snapshot of
the Persistent Disk.
I have a root-mounted Persistent
Disk on that model.
I take a snapshot of it, and
then I can create Persistent
Disks from that snapshot and
start up VMs very fast off of
those Persistent Disks.
I can also create a disk on the
fly with the VM targeted
off of the snapshot.
So there are a lot of nice
configuration options.
I'm not going to go through
that in depth, but if you
click New Instance, you get
prompted for all kinds of
interesting ways to create
a new instance.
So let's go back to Instances.
And this failed because I
didn't have any servers.
If I'm lucky, when I click
it, it does connect.
OK, so what happened
was it served me a
connection through that.
So the 161 is a--
other people may
be connecting.
The 161 is the Load Balancer,
and it connected me
through to Server 0.
So let's clone that window and
pull it out of the Chrome
frame and take a look at some
of the other servers.
So I can actually click on
Server 1, and that reroutes my
WebSocket connection
over to Server 1.
And as you can see, if
I click Ping here, it
shows up on my server.
It's showing up on anybody
who's already connected.
You guys are fast.
I didn't say anything about the
address, and it's like,
bam, you guys are in.
And then if I ping here as well,
you can see it sends it.
So what's happening is these
pings are getting distributed
locally and throughout the
network, which is cool.
Now let's try-- you guys are
going to try to DoS me here.
So let's try something
interesting.
Let's add a VM.
And while we're waiting for that
to happen, let's take a
look at the Cloud console.
There it is.
It's already starting.
And I'll show you the
disks that I have.
I have one disk for
each server here.
You can see the zones.
So the disks are
zone-affiliated, and then I
have my master snapshot.
So if I wanted to create
something with the
characteristics of this
instance, there are two links
down here that I want to
call your attention to.
The first one is REST.
And so this is the JSON
equivalent of how you would
specify this.
And technically, I'm not
saying this correctly.
This is the JSON response from
a get.instance call.
A better way to show this would
be to say, let's create
a new instance, and I would
give some characteristics,
select a bunch of stuff.
And then down at the
bottom somewhere--
there it is, Equivalent
REST or Command Line.
I can click Command Line, and I
get the gcutil equivalent of
that creation, and it'll adjust
to reflect all the
specifications I give.
And then the rest is, as I said
earlier, it's the JSON
equivalent of the RESTful API
to do that instance add.
This is really super-duper
powerful.
I'm really excited about this,
and that's why I'm spending a
lot of time on it.
You can go through the UI and
use it as a very simple
point-and-click mechanism to
specify what you want to do,
and then you have immediate
access to things that tell you
how to do the equivalent of
what you've just done
interactively via code
and via command line.
I think this is totally awesome,
and I'm really proud
of what the engineering team
has done to make that
available to you guys.
Let's check on the instance.
It's now up and running.
So now, you see we have Server
0, 1, 2 and 3, and you may
note that I didn't
refresh anything.
So these web pages just
magically from WebSockets
found out, oh, there's a new
server in the group and we're
getting stuff from it.
And as you can see, we're
still able to send--
actually, there we go.
You guys are hitting this so
hard that I couldn't see the
ping I just sent.
But the other thing I want to
show you very quickly is if I
refresh that whole page,
I end up on Server 1.
So it's just showing you
the Load Balancer
is doing its thing.
Now, one last thing I want to
show is I'm going to kill--
actually, let me do the delete
using the console.
So I'm going to select
Server 3.
I'll scroll down there.
And one thing to
note here, this
robust-io13, that's a tag.
And that gives us the ability
to refer collectively to a
group of servers via the tag,
which is very convenient when
you're administering networking
capabilities.
For example, you could have a
firewall rule that says, let
this traffic in for any VM
with that particular tag.
That's a nice capability.
I won't go too far into
that right now.
But I'm going to delete this
instance, and Cloud Console
will show it spinning.
And let's see if there's
anything else I wanted to show
you on the Cloud Console.
I am going a little late on
time, so let me see what I
have coming up here.
OK.
It's still deleting, so let's
come back to that.
Just in the name of time here,
let's keep marching ahead.
So I've shown you a multi-server
configuration.
We talked about the
single server.
Let me enlarge that for you
guys, and let's look at the
multi server.
We've talked about that.
If you're a real world
application, of course you
never have just a
pure web server.
You have some sort of back-end
datastore, and it's really
important to have that
capability also be resilient
and fault tolerant and
nicely scalable.
And so a typical approach here
is to choose one of many
popular open source or
commercial database servers--
there are a lot of great
choices out there--
and deploy them in this
sort of a fashion.
If you get big enough, you
probably want some sort of a
load balancing capability, an
internal load balancing
capability between your
front-ends and your back-ends.
This is a widely known practiced
standard throughout
the industry.
But there's another option which
I want to talk about,
which is to replace the
whole back-end tier
with a managed service.
And Joe talked earlier about
some of the capabilities we
either have been offering or
have recently announced like
Google Cloud Storage, the Cloud
Datastore, and Cloud SQL.
And the beauty of this approach
is that you tap
into-- it's like what I was
talking about earlier about
taking advantage of Google's DNA
and everything that's gone
into our designs.
You get to tap into a ton of
expertise and technology that
makes it super easy to access
services that are just super
scalable from day one, super
high availability, extremely
replicated, geo-replicated,
all that good stuff.
And you don't have to worry
about managing servers and
processes anymore.
So that's it.
Let me jump back to the demo and
see if it actually worked.
OK, so Server 4 went away.
Again, I didn't refresh
the app.
I didn't do anything.
Let's see if this guy's--
yes.
So you're probably wondering,
did that really work?
It would be nice to have seen
that go away, but anyway,
you'll have to trust
me on that.
But these guys are talking
to each other.
They're exchanging information
dynamically.
They're using a lot of the
capabilities that Joe talked
about earlier using metadata.
The color that they use
is configured as
part of their metadata.
So when I create a new server, I
can assign it a color in its
instance-specific metadata,
and it'll do
that or change it.
So a lot of nice capabilities
here along with the load
balancing and the snapshots
and all that good stuff.
So I'll try to finish up here
because I want to leave a
little bit of time
for questions.
The last thing I wanted to
mention is just a few simple
takeaways that I want
to leave you with.
So it's a summary of what we
felt were the key points we
were sharing today.
One is that reliable systems
are really a combination of
infrastructure--
that's what we're trying
to give you and
do a great job of--
design--
that's your apps and all the
logic and business processes
that you guys work with every
day-- and then people.
And we talked about that
earlier, some of the good
people processes that you need
to think about when you're
building reliable systems.
It's super important to manage
your config, your deployment,
and your scaling as if were
code, as it were one of the
critical artifacts of your
business because it really is.
So the app I've shown is a toy,
and I think it shows a
fairly cool amount of stuff that
you can do on your own.
But as Joe mentioned earlier,
there are a lot of great
options out there to do more
sophisticated and declarative
type processes around that.
Fast-starting servers
are awesome.
They rock.
They help you scale better.
They help with your
availability, and we're
looking forward to making
resources available even
faster in the future.
Power tools to build
self-configuring, shared,
little, stateless servers along
the lines of what Joe
showed you earlier are
really important.
Take advantage of managed
services.
As I just mentioned, there's a
real value, I think, in terms
of not having to reinvent
the wheel there.
And plan for all the
different types of
outages that are possible.
I didn't actually show this.
I'd meant to, but I just
killed one server.
I'm not going to take any more
time on it, but if I had
killed 2 and 3, which were the
two in the 1 zone, you would
have seen that the Load Balancer
was still happy, and
all the service requests would
have just gone to one zone.
So it perfectly would have
tolerated losing an entire
zone in that model.
And finally, stay tuned
for more awesomeness.
We've mentioned the
Load Balancing.
We haven't mentioned System
Monitoring, but that's another
thing that we're working
on actively.
And we're really excited about
continuing to add great value
to this product.
And we have something called the
Early Access Program that
you can link to here.
It's a way to sign up to get
access to some of these
capabilities.
And finally, your homework
is to take some of these
guidelines and build super
awesome systems.
We're really excited to see what
you guys are going to do
with Google Compute Engine
and the Google
Cloud Platform in general.
Here's a few places you can
learn some more about the
Compute Engine and
Cloud Platform.
I'm going to make these
slides available via
that link at the top.
They're not there right now.
If you go there right
now, it won't work.
Within about an hour from the
end of this talk, I'll upload
the slides, and you'll be
able to find them at
bit.ly/robust-io13.
And with that, I'd
like to thank you
guys for coming today.
And thank you, Joe.
So we'll take--
[APPLAUSE]
MARC COHEN: And I think we
have one minute and eight
seconds for questions.
I apologize for that, but we'll
stay here and talk as
long as you guys would like.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MARC COHEN: So the question was,
to manage infrastructure
and code, what kind of
tools do we use?
So we have a bunch of internal,
as you would guess,
elaborate tools and processes
at Google that we use to
manage our code and our
development cycles and
deployments and all
that stuff.
I don't think we're allowed
to go into too
much depth on that.
Joe was talking about some of
the open source options like
Chef and Puppet, as well as
the commercial Scalr and
Rightscale.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOE BEDA: We're always looking
at new opportunities to take
some of our internal technology
and learnings and
externalize them.
We just have to prioritize what
we think will provide the
most value and work our
way down the list.
So eventually, hopefully we'll
find a way to get that stuff
out to everybody.
MARC COHEN: Other questions?
We've either put you guys to
sleep, or we've answered--
oh, here's a question.
JOE BEDA: Do you mind
using the mic?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The scheduled
maintenance that Google
undertakes regularly, just if
you could speak to patterns
for designing robust systems
around that?
JOE BEDA: Around the scheduled
maintenance?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOE BEDA: Well, it's
essentially
practicing for failure.
I think you get some warning.
It's a way for you to test your
procedures and your systems.
I think because we do have those
types of maintenances
internally also, it leads us to
build systems that you have
to be honest with yourself,
and you can't cheat.
You can't get away with it.
MARC COHEN: Were you referring
to the specific schedule that
Google has?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MARC COHEN: Yeah, so the rule
of thumb is the zones
currently go into a maintenance
window roughly
twice a year.
And they go into that state
for up to two weeks.
AUDIENCE: A live service
at that point, you
would move it across?
MARC COHEN: Right, and so we
have some capabilities in that
area to help, like the gcutil
command that I was using to
show how to create instances
also has a capability for
migrating virtual machines with
attached Persistent Disks
from one zone to another.
But we're continuing to work
on that area to make the
process simpler and less
impactful on people.
But we also feel like if you
design your system so that it
tolerates a scheduled outage,
then you're doing the right
thing for any eventuality.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARC COHEN: I think
we're all done?
Oh, one more.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [? Adi. ?]
MARC COHEN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Now, right now,
there is a limitation in
Google App Engine, like
60 seconds for
processing a request.
That is an App Engine.
MARC COHEN: So the question was
about the 60 second limit
on Google--
AUDIENCE: In App Engine, but
the question is, does the
limitation still continue when
you introduce the Load
Balancer in Compute Engine?
MARC COHEN: So is the 60 second
time out manifested in
Google Compute Engine?
AUDIENCE: No, in App Engine.
So in Google Compute Engine,
if you introduce a Load
Balancer, would that still be
a 60 second limitation?
JOE BEDA: The type of Load
Balancer that we're demoing
here is a low enough level
that it just forwards TCP
connections.
And so it's up to you to
implement whatever you want on
top of that.
So you can use it for things
beyond just HTTP also.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOE BEDA: All right.
MARC COHEN: So we'll
be around.
You'll be here for
a little bit?
JOE BEDA: Yeah.
MARC COHEN: We'll hang out for
a little while if anybody
wants to come down and talk.
But thank you guys very much.
Hope you had a great
conference,
and have a good time.
[APPLAUSE]